[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's super zoomed in
I need to see if I can adjust that
what is happening
where oh here we are okay there's just a
a bit of a delay
hey there we go
okay okay nice oh you can see it there
yes
yeah I I am a I am a viewer as well at
this point very nice
cool
all right we are up and running uh if
you
joined us promptly
at 8pm eastern time uh thank you for
your patience we're uh just a couple
minutes late but we are ready to start
I'm gonna pick up my backup audio here
and cool
so we're up and running so
thank you everyone for joining us uh for
this big one-year celebration of macro
Factor uh it is exactly the one year
anniversary uh which means that this
fell on a Friday night which makes it
even more impressive that people are
here joining us we really appreciate
your willingness to start your weekend
with a celebration with a macro Factor
family uh so Greg one year in how you
feeling
man I'm feeling I'm feeling great
feeling better than I better better than
I even thought I would how are you
feeling Eric
Beyond needing to adjust the camera
I am feeling good the camera is super
crooked
all right uh you
well never mind I guess it's
there's like a
15 second lag that looks good that looks
good
yeah you're you're slightly more in the
middle of the frame than I am now but
that's all right that's all right I have
the the presents to make up for it
perfect yeah the way that it's angled
I'm getting
it's an optical illusion but I'm getting
out angled very aggressively right now
that's completely untrue I'm just a
physically larger person than you yeah I
can live with it someone asked who the
host is here and that's an interesting
question because I think people know
that with Fireside Chats obviously Greg
you are the host
um and those are historically our worst
reviewed episodes usually get the lowest
views a lot of one star and two star
reviews well I mean like we talked about
before a lot of prestige media doesn't
necessarily have the highest viewership
but uh
you know if that's if that's the only
if that's the only metric you're looking
at I think you're leaving a lot on the
table yeah that's an interesting
perspective but you know the the regular
episodes are usually within my
jurisdiction this is you know kind of
outside of the traditional context of
either
um
a fireside chat or a traditional podcast
episode had we started with no technical
issues I probably would have claimed uh
ownership of this and been the primary
host but since we had a couple minute
delay there and a crooked camera I think
that this is probably yours I'm willing
to let you take this one I would go so
far as to say you were managing the
stream setup and it's all kind of
running through through your device so I
would say that that you're the producer
and I'm the on-air Talent inter
situation
all right well someone said that
technically the uh the good people
joining us are the hosts given that we
are going to open up the floor and take
plenty of questions that's true I agree
I agree Jonathan this is in I I
appreciate you for going out on this
limb you you can take the L on our
behalf yeah
so uh
this is an interesting question just to
get us started here and by the way
everyone in the chat uh thanks for
joining us someone asked uh penguin
asked do you guys usually talk at 1X
speed
and obviously the answer is no we we
clearly talk at about 0.7 speed yeah
which is why uh Greg have you ever
talked to someone who listens to the
podcast at 1X speed
uh I don't think I've ever talked to
someone who who listens to the podcast
um but no so on that topic I will say
I'm Southern so I have an excuse but in
your case you just talk slow
well no you you're Southern and that's
your excuse per your own words I think a
lot
that's my excuse sure I like to let
ideas percolate and I like to let them
come out when they're ready you know so
I I do talk very slowly
um but it is funny when when Aya and I
and my girlfriend started dating
um she had to basically relearn
conversational cadences because it
became very apparent that if she did not
slow herself down she would simply never
hear from me again like every time I was
about to formulate a thought and speak
the opportunity had passed by and the
conversation just moved on without me
yeah so the the thing I'll say is that
my my speaking Cadence varies a lot
based on what I'm talking about uh
because I also try to think and pick my
words wisely when we're talking about
science or research or anything like
that
um but especially when you get any uh
any alcohol in my system I think my
speaking Kate either my speaking Cadence
roughly doubles or
um my my mental processing slows down
twofold so I feel like I'm talking
faster but um
yeah and also just like when I'm not
talking about research I I am not quite
as slow of a talker as normal anyway
that's enough about our speaking Cadence
uh we're here to answer questions uh and
uh you know help help out the folks who
are tuning in live so let's uh
let's jump right into it I would say
well before we do that though if I may
um first obviously you know we want to
thank everyone for joining us but we
also want to thank everyone even if
they're listening to this later on
recording I want to thank everyone for
your support during year one of macro
Factor it we launched
365 days ago it's been a fantastic first
year uh we are so sincerely thankful for
your support as users of macro factor
and also you know the way that we've
approached this product in this company
I mean we owe a lot to our users because
of all the incredible feedback we've
gotten over the last year between uh you
know the the Facebook group The Reddit
personal messages the uh the public
roadmap where people submit feature
requests uh you know I I think we do
really view it as a bit of a
collaborative effort where the users
really are part of the process here and
part of the journey with macro factors
development so thank you so much for
your support over the last year and
if you are interested in kind of taking
a walk down memory lane or if you're new
to macro factor and you want to get
caught up to speed and figure out how we
got from launch to here we have a new
article on the macro Factor website by
Lindsay it is excellent it is the annual
report so macro factorapp.com annual
report 2022 and if you're listening live
I I linked it in the chat that's what we
can do with technology we absolutely can
uh but it talks about a look back at our
first year how we got here and more
importantly where we're going moving
forward yeah it gives a little bit of a
a hint about what the future has in
store or a preview I guess for macro
factors so thanks so much for joining us
and if you want to check that out it
exists and it's fantastic Lindsay did an
incredible job with that absolutely uh
now let's go ahead and respond to some
questions yeah let's do it let's do it
so
um let's let's start with the question
from Daniel Brown who put a question in
the chat before we even went live is
there a way that I can
actually so it's through yours is there
a button you can put you can push to
like distinguish a question and put it
on screen I don't know if that's a thing
in YouTube chat whatever it doesn't
matter we're not we know yeah I can just
read it aloud so uh Daniel says congrats
on your first year thank you Daniel I've
been loving the app what are what was
the biggest unexpected challenge the
team had to overcome in year one
um
so
I think
personally
personally I've been uh very surprised
at overall how smoothly things have gone
um seems like a trap yeah it does like
I've I've described it as like almost
eerily smoothly like uh you know it's it
seems like kind of a a Road Runner uh
and Wiley Coyote type situation where
the road has seemed too straight and
clear and it's like we're going to run
into a wall that the Road Runner has
painted at some point
um but but overall like it's been pretty
[ __ ] smooth I think that the biggest
challenge we've had at least at least
from our and mine in yours is uh
balancing work responsibilities just
because like we do have a decent number
of irons in the fire and we
are also like we're we're very active
with specifically macro Factor stuff
interacting in the groups answering
questions
um
you know talking to our developers Corey
and Rebecca about Road mapping stuff
um and yeah like I mean I'm sure people
don't care too much about the Gory
details but you know I I would say that
we're probably averaging around 20 25
hours per week specifically on macro
Factor stuff which on top of Stronger by
science stuff the podcast Mass stuff is
you know like it's it's been at least
somewhat challenging for me to do
everything I need to do to contribute to
macro Factor while also maintaining at
least like some semblance of work-life
balance which may not be what Daniel was
getting at there because that's not
really an app related challenge but I I
stand by my initial answer on that like
that that stuff has been going so much
smoother than than I could have
anticipated yeah one thing that comes to
mind for me it's it's less of a headache
for us and more just a general thing but
like anytime you get into a new industry
or a new sector there are just like
weird little roadblocks that you have to
navigate in terms of just the procedural
elements
um and so like you would think that like
between the different places where
people get their apps and the different
um what do they call like operating
systems like you would think that there
was like a really straightforward way
that you just do one thing and then like
both sides of that equation in like the
the Google and the Apple stores are both
like oh excellent yeah that you followed
the template that's very easy the fact
that sometimes there are kind of
different things you have to do uh
behind the scenes to appease each one
that's been something that you know
every now and then we're like you know
you run into a little snag with that but
Corey and Rebecca are really really good
so they've navigated all that stuff so
that we don't have to do any difficult
things or think too hard oh yeah for
sure but um no it's been really really
smooth and and yeah like you said the
biggest thing is just biting off another
very very large project and and
rearranging things to accommodate that
yes
all right so moving on Ashley Dawson
says uh she loves micronutrient tracking
but without any benchmarks to compare it
against I don't know if I'm hitting
optimal levels of each any plans to
include guidelines or rdis in the app or
where could I find those yeah so that
that isn't something we've implemented
yet but uh like I said we we've linked
the annual report in chat you should
check that out I think you'll be uh very
pleasantly hopefully not surprised but
but just pleased in general so in terms
of upcoming things for this forthcoming
year
um there's there's a lot that we want to
get done but the three like big high
priorities right out of the gate are
um so if you've been using the app for a
pretty good chunk of this year you know
that we
um like several several months ago uh
completely revamped the food logger and
once again by we I mean core and Rebecca
Eric and I are not are not app
developers
um and as part of that there there's a
new design system within the app as well
which one is is just kind of to make it
feel like a smooth cohesive experience
and two uh like part of the reason
behind the new design system is so we
can scale to other screen sizes so
uh food logger was first next is if you
currently have version 1.5.0 or later
you can opt into the Beta of the
dashboard redesign which we're in the
process of of rolling out to everyone
now and then uh kind of the last set of
screens that we need to bring into
compliance with the new design system
just as kind of a priority that may not
be exciting to everyone listening to
this but something that we definitely
need to get done to make sure that the
whole app is a cohesive visual
experience is revamping the the food log
like the actual food log screen and the
the Nutri like the food detail View and
day in review screens so that's one
thing we need to get done uh another
thing we need to get done uh once again
Downstream of the new design system is
rolling out a version for desktop and
also like landscape view for tablets and
then our third really high priority
going into this year is expanded micro
nutrient analytics so things like rdas
rdis allowing you to specify particular
things that you might want to keep an
eye on so if you want to monitor your
fiber intake or like saturated fat
intake or total water intake for the day
and kind of like demarcate those as
nutrients you want to pay specific
attention to that's one of the things
kind of under that story being able to
click on a particular micronutrient and
see like what your top sources for
getting or both micros and macros like
you know be able to click on iron and
see what your top sources of iron are
for the day or over a longer period of
time
um so anyway that that is the third of
the like really high priorities going
into this year so you are correct for
micronutrient tracking rdas rdis or dris
whatever you know that stuff better than
you
um they're not in the app yet but that
that is uh definitely an area where
we're going towards this year yeah and
the good news is there there are until
we get them directly placed into the app
there are a lot of different places if
you have a particular micronutrient that
you're you're interested in there are
quite a few places online most a lot of
government-run websites where you can
just put in very basic demographic
information and you can get uh the
metric that you're looking for in terms
of you know for each micronutrient some
of them have an RDA some have a dri some
just have a like a safe upper limit and
lower limit and stuff like that but
usually that stuff isn't too hard to dig
up on the internet but absolutely a high
priority is getting that stuff straight
into the app so you don't have to do
that digging in the future
all right so uh let's see the Greek
Trojan says I know there are no silver
bullets but any interesting insights
that you've data mined from successful
dieters that you wouldn't have
necessarily predicted so no uh the
reason for that in part is that macro
factor is very very uh obsessed and
preoccupied with data privacy so uh your
data is end-to-end encrypted and it's
stored on secure Cloud servers and like
I'm sure no one actually reads privacy
policies but if you read the privacy
policy like we we aren't sharing your
data with anyone and we aren't even
using it for our own internal research
purposes we will at some point uh but
when that occurs there will be like a
specific opt-in so
um
like
yeah the our our capacity to data mine
is inherently limited by uh a very
expansive privacy policy so you know
like essentially we're doing as little
with your data as we possibly can to
still make the app do what we want it to
do so uh yeah no we we haven't gleaned
any insights from data mining although
again that that is something we'll
probably be interested in in the future
though again after there's some sort of
like specific opt-in so users know
they're letting us use their data for
that purpose uh but I would say just
from interacting in in the groups
uh because I mean there there have been
plenty of people posting questions
challenges that they're facing Etc
I think that
like this isn't particularly exciting
but if anything I think that like
Optimal weights of or optimal rates of
weight loss might even be slower than
just kind of like normal recommendations
suggest like I would say of
probably three quarters of the people
who post in the Facebook group or
subreddit they're having struggles with
something
um most of the time what helps them out
is just reducing their target rate of
weight loss uh because like we can look
at the research like there's a
difference between practicality and
Physiology and physiologically speaking
like most people are pretty fine from
like a lean mass retention perspective
going up to losing about one percent of
body weight per week but once you're you
know I would say above like the mid 100
pounds like if you're anywhere close to
like 200 pounds or certainly above
um like losing around two pounds per
week may not sound like much that's one
percent per week if you're about 200.
but that that does still imply
approximately in a thousand calorie per
day deficit where especially if you kind
of have a uh like a Thrifty metabolic
phenotype or you just don't have a
particularly active lifestyle like that
thousand calorie per day deficit that
like you'll you'll feel that
so even though that is like a very
physiologically tolerable
um rate of weight loss it doesn't mesh
that well with a lot of people's
Lifestyles or just how much that they're
happy and content to eat so yeah I I
think
like I that that was something I already
knew but it's just been like hammered
home by like so many individual cases of
people being like hey like if I'm
hitting my numbers things are going well
but my God it's it's hard to hit my
numbers and I'm only aiming for like you
know point eight one percent of body
weight per week like what's going on
here
um and more often than not just saying
like yeah bump it down to like point
four point five percent of body weight
per week
um seems to help a lot of people so yeah
that's that's probably been and like I
said that's that's not like Cutting Edge
mind-blowing [ __ ]
um but yeah that's that's definitely
been something that's that's been
hammered home for me yeah you know as
much as I enjoy reading into the
nitty-gritty physiology research and as
as useful as that is in developing this
type of app
um there's no question that uh you know
the physiologically
uh you know highest rate of weight loss
within the optimal range that's not
always going to mesh really well with
what is uh subjectively enjoyable to
implement you know and the more that we
look into it and interact with users and
even just going back to like one-on-one
coaching and our own dieting experience
you know you run into questions about
what is uh what are some of the biggest
challenges with successful weight loss
and long-term maintenance of weight loss
rarely do you have to go deep in the
physiology Playbook it's usually
some convergence of getting the right
goal identifying the appropriate Target
for rate of weight change and then
addressing some of the psychological and
behavioral elements that underpin eating
Behavior and to me uh you know that's
one of the reasons that so much thought
and effort went into the way things are
presented within the app is to make sure
that we are
not unnecessarily exacerbating uh you
know psychological and behavioral
elements of dieting that are actually
deleterious or can obstruct one's
progress you know we try to make the app
kind of a low stress environment where
where we can say okay let's focus a
little bit you know we know these
targets are going to work but you know
like you said a lot of times the advice
is like hey let's let's slow down a
little bit with the rate of weight loss
not because of necessarily physiology
but because of just behavior and
psychology and also along with that
another thing that seems to be uh very
predictive of success and just
subjective enjoyment of the process
is having just a little bit of
flexibility in terms of cognitive
restraint so sometimes uh you know one
of the things that can hold people back
is yeah maybe they are pursuing a rate
of weight loss that is just not
compatible with their lifestyle and
preferences and that needs to be
addressed but also sometimes aiming for
Perfection can really get in the way of
making excellent but not quite perfect
progress you know so sometimes people
will if they can't track perfectly for a
day or two they just kind of throw their
hands up and say screw it and they get
out of their typical habits and
behaviors that have been supporting
their success along the way and so the
people who are who are very comfortable
with the idea of having very good
consistent uh tracking but not
necessarily perfect tracking a hundred
percent of the time those people seem to
avoid that trap of getting overly
discouraged and saying well if I can't
do it perfectly I'm not going to do it
at all and things like that so
um like you said rate of weight loss is
big and also just kind of focusing on uh
the psychological and behavioral
elements that allow you to keep going
through a little bit of friction some
challenges some variables you didn't
plan for
um that that stuff can be really really
big yeah absolutely
all right uh so uh Zhao Pedrosa said or
asks do you have any plans on
translating macro factor to Portuguese
any day I would like to give some months
of it to my mom as a gift but she
doesn't speak English uh first of all
hello to you and your mother uh that's
that's a very nice thing for a son to do
but uh to answer your question
it's hard to say explicitly
um and there are some things that are
going through my head right now that I
don't think I either can or should
publicly talk about yet but what I can
say is that from a kind of short to
medium term priority
um
Corey and Rebecca are doing some work on
the back end of the app to enable and
open the door for internationalization
uh and there there are just like a lot
of little things that need to be done
there so like for example currently the
text in the app is like all hard-coded
so when you see just like nutrition on
the nutrition panel like in in the code
it's just it just says nutrition and
that's what's being called
um so you know they're to enable
internationalization instead of just
like hard coding every single language
there's kind of like a a process of
development that involves uh going
through and making sure for all of those
text strings it's not just call calling
for like a hard-coded value but based on
the language someone uh
says that they use or the the region
they're using the app in to know to call
like specific uh strings to correspond
with with the language the person uses
um so I can't yet say precisely why
they're doing that work but that is uh
something that is that is currently uh
in the works and going on behind the
scenes
um
so to answer the question about
Portuguese specific we're developing our
own language uh and macro factor is
going to feature that yes we're uh ah
[ __ ] I was gonna I was gonna make a
reference but I I forget what it is what
was that language in the 90s that people
were Esperanto I've never heard of this
in my life oh man in the in the 90s like
kind of during the the end of History
Halcyon Days After the cold war ends and
people are like oh this is going to be a
a golden era of peace and prosperity
which like boy Francis fukuyama you you
sure would have felt dumb if you had
access to a time machine in the 90s uh
to see today anyway
um there was this movement that to bring
the world together with like a single
International Language where you know
it's just kind of the type of thing
where like everyone could just become
bilingual like you don't have to worry
about learning multiple different
languages if you want to interact with
people all around the world it's just
you know if you're born in France you
learn French and Esperanto if you're
born in China you learn like Mandarin or
like whatever Chinese dialect is spoken
in in the region you're in and Esperanto
and it's just like one language that
kind of like borrowed a little bit from
a bunch of different language families
and it's like yeah just everyone learned
this one and we'll be good
um anyway I don't think [ __ ] anyone
speaks Esperanto uh but no so uh getting
back to answering the question as far as
Portuguese goes that is not
some so like localizing the app for a
Portuguese audience isn't something that
is
strictly speaking in the imminent plans
but we are interested in the
internationalization process and
probably gradually over over a period of
of years like not months but years
um translating the app into other
languages
um and and kind of going global from
there
um
and I will say just kind of on a on a
gut level uh Portuguese would be
probably one of our higher priorities
um
in part just because like speaking very
plainly the fitness industry is just so
big in Brazil like it seems like a
golden opportunity
um so
on that front like I certainly can't
make any promises but if if we do start
going further down the road of
internationalization
um Portuguese would probably I think it
would comfortably be within our
top 10 priorities for for languages to
get macro factor into but uh that that's
not something to like keep keep an eye
out for for the next year or anything
like that yeah
can I answer a question yeah go for it
all right we got a question from Beth
and the question is how the heck
do I get enough protein as a vegetarian
who doesn't like Dairy very much am I
looking at two protein shakes a day for
the rest of my life so the reason I
picked this is you know we do have quite
a few users in the app who are on
vegetarian diets obviously and I am
indeed one of them
um and yeah so there are a lot of
different options trying to get more
protein on a vegetarian diet
um you know fortunately one of the nice
things about the app I should say before
we get into specific protein sources is
there is a lot of flexibility where you
can adjust your protein goal to what
works for you right so uh I I think it's
I think all too often people are a
little bit nervous about going down to
like a moderate protein diet or even the
low setting within the app and you know
the low setting within the app is not
like absolute bare minimum to to be a
healthy person right it's not like the
bottom of the barrel RDA for protein
even the low protein is is kind of the
lowest we would recommend for someone
who has body composition related goals
and it factors in obviously whether or
not you're lifting weights and things
like that so uh low is not like you've
probably heard in the fitness industry
you can't be on a low protein diet first
of all
I think the magnitude of the effect of
under eating protein is probably
overblown more often than not in the
fitness industry and also low for us is
low within the app it's not like a
categorically low protein diet overall
so that's the first thing to say the
second thing is uh there's a lot of
different protein sources that are
compatible with a vegetarian diet uh you
know
um so you know someone mentioned you
know eggs whey protein are still on the
table I think the question basically
said don't like Dairy very much so maybe
whey being Dairy based is also off the
table uh protein shakes obviously there
are non-dairy protein shakes I
personally have a pea based protein
shake that I really like it's uh took a
minute to get used to I'm not gonna lie
it's not as good as a dairy-based
protein shake in terms of flavor uh but
I I honestly think that's an unforced
error they decided to not use artificial
sweeteners and like here is it Stevia
quote unquote sweetened uh I think they
used monk fruit extract which is better
than Stevia that's not that bad yeah but
but I think they could have gone a long
way if they just used some different
things for texture and sweetening I I
think they were trying to thread the
needle and say like this is not just
vegan but it's also like nothing
artificial of any kind and it's like
some artificial stuff is very good yeah
like it's very nice so um but anyway you
know there's a lot of different uh
protein supplements that are out there
for uh vegetarian and vegan diets uh
eggs are are out there it's a thing you
could do and if you live in a us if you
live close enough to a rural area where
there's a lot of farming if you are on a
vegetarian diet more for just like
animal welfare related reasons like I
get my eggs from an animal rescue where
the chickens are actually rescued and uh
they're happy as can be they they
honestly have a better life than I do so
they always joke that it's mainly a an
animal rescue for dogs and they they get
like
they get like a couple thousand dogs a
year placed into homes through this
rescue like it's a huge huge uh dog
rescue that they run but they rescue uh
uh uh farm animals as well and they just
have this huge compound and all the
animals are chilling and you know the
chickens are going to lay their eggs
anyway so they're like cool we'll sell
them and then the proceeds go to the you
know taking care of the other animals so
nice it's pretty cool so you might be
able to find a situation like that but
then when it comes to just good
old-fashioned plant-based sources
there's a lot out there
um you know tofu
my first experience with tofu was not
good because I didn't know what to do
with it but with tofu you can do some
really nice things like if you use a
little bit of corn starch and cook it
you can crisp it up really well such
that it imitates uh meat in a lot of
different dishes that call for like a
nice crispy kind of textured meat
um
so tofu is has a lot of Versatility
you'll see tofu used in things all the
way from almost as like a meat stand in
to like desserts you know with some of
the softer tofus uh what's the one
seitan I think I don't know how you
pronounce that I've always just assumed
it was like Seton or Satan yeah but
there's no way that's correct probably
not but but it's very good
um you know you'll find out a lot uh in
various vegetarian dishes uh a lot of
different beans and legumes that I like
to lean on
um so like uh you know if if you get
like a rice cooker you can do I mean
rice with chickpeas and literally like
any kind of Bean or legume uh you know
that's kind of a staple meal for me
um but yeah there's a lot of different
options out there one thing that I would
recommend though if you're like just
getting into a vegetarian diet or you've
been doing it for a while and just
sticking to a very very small list of
Staples explore cuisines in areas where
meat just isn't eaten that regularly or
is harder to come by like one of the
things that my girlfriend and I are both
vegetarian when we're traveling one of
the first things we do is like if if
we're just struggling to find a place
with options it's like if we can find a
restaurant that serves a lot of Indian
food or a lot of Vietnamese food like
there are certain Cuisines where there
are so many vegetarian options you can
start there look at a menu and figure
out where the protein is coming from in
those dishes because
you know people like to arrange their
dishes with a decent amount of protein
in them it's it's kind of even if it's
coming from plant-based sources so uh
yeah I would say exploring different
cuisines
and seeing how they work different types
of plant-based sources into that Cuisine
that that's been a really helpful
approach for me
sounds good all right so uh penguin asks
what's your what's your favorite
nutrient uh penguin themself is a big
calcium fan
do you have a favorite nutrient
oh boy favorite nutrient
um
well I I guess I would have to say
protein because if you exist in the
sport nutrition world it's just uh
you you can't make it out of there alive
without developing a great appreciation
for protein and frankly it is kind of
how I how I structure my meals I start
out by saying okay what's my protein
Source here and then I build out from
there so protein is is kind of the
generic one
um and yeah I think that's unfortunately
the one I'm gonna have to settle with
what about you uh
uh probably so I'm Googling something
real quick
um
so my my first thought was probably uh
lecithin uh it's a good emulsifier and I
I like making uh emulsified sauces and
whatnot
um
but then my other like
probably just like any of the ones that
that make onions taste like onions it's
hard to overstate how much I like onions
I think they're delicious
um
so uh
yeah I'm not gonna try to pronounce too
many of these oh Allison is in there
that's that's the big one from garlic uh
but yeah like in any of those those uh
nice pungent sulfurous compounds from
onions I think are incredibly Pleasant
awesome uh let's see
so here here's something that that I
think you could talk about a bit just uh
talking about rigid versus flexible uh
cognitive restraint uh Ashley Dawson uh
specifically says uh from a
psychological approach she loves the
adherence neutral uh philosophy within
macro Factor
um she says personally if I've gone over
my recommended cows for the day I don't
need any red lines or in-app call outs
to rub it in do you want to just like
expand on that from like a cognitive
restraint perspective because I I think
that is something that folks are maybe
confused about initially when they start
using macro Factor especially if they
come from uh kind of more traditional
and restrictive kind of dieting
backgrounds yeah I think
um you know we've covered it in bits and
pieces just kind of part by part over
the past year or so but one of the
overarching goals with macro Factor was
to make sure that we were designing it
such that the user experience and the
design elements were reflective of what
we consider to be best practices uh in
terms of just being compatible with the
health psychology literature so uh when
we were developing uh macro factor I as
you know Greg I got really into reading
Health psychology textbooks and just
digging into the literature and and
saying like
where can we improve upon the current
model of how a lot of these food
tracking apps operate and I didn't have
to get too many pages in before I
realized that almost like the industry
Norm the kind of standard approach is
really incompatible with a lot of the
research pertaining to health psychology
specifically as it pertains to eating
behaviors there's a fantastic review
paper a couple years ago can I just butt
in real quick I I scroll to the bottom
of the chat for the first time in a
while someone was asking where so so
Huffman tree asks uh are they answering
questions from this chat or is it
somewhere else we are answering
questions from chat where uh like trying
to address them in in roughly the order
they came in so if you scroll back like
two-thirds of the way that's that's
where we currently are
um so yes this is the place to and to
answer questions uh and I will try to do
a better job of bouncing back and forth
between kind of the bottom of the chat
and top of the chat but yes if you're
watching this live and asking questions
live we are exclusively taking uh
questions from from the YouTube chat
here so yeah you you are in the right
place to to be asking questions there
yeah so um you know there's a great
review paper a couple years ago that uh
my arch nemesis Dr Eric Helms was a
co-author on a very inferior Eric but uh
they talked about some of the research
involving rigid versus flexible
cognitive restraint and someone
enforcing rigid restraint uh has a
tendency to create really rigid
guidelines and dichotomize their
adherence to those guidelines right so
my goal was
180 carbs today and if I eat 183 carbs
today I failed because I went over and
that's bad that's kind kind of an
example of rigid cognitive restraint and
what we find is that in the short term
employing rigid cognitive restraint in
the context of dieting
is subjectively a bit unfavorable it
tends to lend itself to some very
negative psychological processes and
just subjectively a a low enjoyment of
the process of dieting so looking at
just purely subjective and psychological
outcomes in the short term a flexible
approach to cognitive restraint is much
more preferable it seems to support a
happier more enjoyable experience with
dieting uh and and so but you know some
people say well I'm I'm really hardcore
about my dieting I don't need to enjoy
it I just want to you know put my head
down put in the work trust the process
and do the damn thing unfortunately what
we find also is that rigid cognitive
restraint also just doesn't seem to lead
to favorable long-term outcomes with
dieting you know it seems to be over the
long term a very demotivating Factor
that can lead to what they call
motivational collapse and ultimately the
cessation of a diet basically you
discontinue the diet because you are
very frustrated because you've set all
these rigid guidelines frame them as
dichotomous and you just find based on
your internal framing that you fail and
fail and fail a fail and fail and so at
some point you say why do I keep trying
this like I'm clearly not doing this
well so flexible cognitive restraint
offers a completely different
alternative where you give yourself some
wiggle room you you give yourself a
little bit of flexibility and you say
okay my goal is to eat you know 180
grams of carbs a day if I eat
189 sometimes and 173 sometimes
sometimes I might even go way over but
after I go way over I get back on track
the next day you're giving yourself some
flexibility and the goal is to routinely
get close to the objective not be
perfect every single time with no
deviations and so it doesn't become a a
success or fail type of situation it
becomes a closer or further from Target
type of situation so we try to be really
really intentional about how the app
actually functions mechanically so that
we reinforce flexible cognitive
restraint as people are approaching
targets and then when it comes to just
the feedback and the design elements we
wanted to make sure that we are not
giving demotivating messages that are
punitive you know numbers turning red
thing you know warnings and and flashing
banners and all stuff like that we try
to make sure that the the app
one of the terms we use is a diet
sidekick you know where it is supporting
you along the way supporting a flexible
sustainable approach to dieting and
ultimately serving as a form of very
positive guidance as you go along so uh
it was a very intentional effort and the
biggest misconception people have in
this area is people call
any form of dieting where you have macro
targets or calorie targets people tend
to group that into this kind of category
that they call flexible dieting and what
they mean by that term is it is flexible
with regards to Food Source yeah so your
20 grams of protein can come from
chicken or eggs or tofu that's the kind
of flexibility that they're talking
about with that term but there are a lot
of people who do flexible dieting with
extremely rigid cognitive restraint and
so what we wanted to do was leverage
that Health psychology research
implement it and make sure that we
supported uh users in their journey and
made sure that we reinforced flexible
restraint
all right so let's uh let let's get an
exercise question and also just so you
guys know
um
you know this is a one-year uh
celebration for macro Factor but we we
are here to answer questions about
virtually anything
um so I'm not seeing that many training
questions in the chat which is totally
fine but just letting people know it's
not like we're only on here to talk
about macro factor and promote it uh so
let's just let's just address a
completely unrelated question from Mori
kogoro any tips on bouncing out of the
hole for astagrass squats uh sometimes
I'll get it right and the rep feels way
lighter and easier so yeah if you have
um
if you are doing astograph squats and
you and you want to get kind of bouncy
with it uh my biggest tip would be to
control the eccentric pretty well most
of the way down so when I see people who
have who are trying to get like a good
bounce out of the bottom of a squat
specifically doing astrograss squats
like really deep squats uh more often
than not if it if their bounce is like
pretty inconsistent and and they feel
like they don't have a good Groove a lot
of times it's because they're kind of
starting their their rapid descent a
little bit too high so
um like generally if you're going for a
bounce your the the end of your
eccentric is generally going to be
relatively quick for that rapid rebound
maybe a bit of of stretch shortening
cycle action coming into the mix
um but
what's important there is to make sure
that you have a really smooth and solid
repeatable groove on all of your reps
and so when I see people with with
inconsistent bounces most of the time
it's because they have inconsistent
grooves and most of the time they have
inconsistent grooves because they're
either going too fast for The Eccentric
or they're starting the kind of fast
final descent a bit too high so one of
the things that might help with your
consistency is taking a pretty well
controlled relatively slow eccentric
down to the point where you're only like
just above parallel uh and then only for
that very very bottom part of of the The
Eccentric do you just kind of like Let
Go slightly let yourself accelerate into
the hole and then bounce up out of there
so uh essentially like it's it's a lot
easier to stay under control and in like
a smooth and repeatable Groove if that
drop is short rather than if the drop is
long and also like and this is just kind
of my my n equals one experience
um like I've experimented quite a bit
with with eccentric speed because I I
also do especially for like Max lifts uh
rely pretty heavily on that bounce and I
found that like it really only needs to
be
maybe four or five inches tops like you
you don't want to be be going fast for
like the entire eccentric find yourself
in the bottom and be like oh where the
[ __ ] am I hopefully I get a good bounce
um so keep like that nice smooth slow
descent most of the way down and then
yeah for for the last like maybe four to
six inches that's where you get that
little drop bounce poop and and come up
and that that should be uh quite a bit
more repeatable than uh than the
alternative
good stuff yeah yeah I used to squat a
low bar ass to Grass bouncing out of the
bottom and uh man
being young is nice uh low bar asked to
grass is Quite a feat I used to have the
hips for it and I don't anymore uh I've
got a question I'd like to answer that
is just kind of a general guidance about
uh cutting you know this comes up a lot
so Matt B asked
um so Matt Matt B is about five weeks
into a cut it's going well
congratulations Matt glad to hear that
uh but Matt does not have an end goal in
mind
and so the question is you know how
should Matt know when to stop with the
cut and a lot of people have been asking
questions in this General genre of like
when do I when should I stop cutting how
long am I allowed to cut before I need
to do a maintenance phase how long
should that maintenance phase be you
know there's a lot of questions in that
general area and the good news which is
uh minimally helpful but maximally
flexible is it it really does there's no
right or wrong answer here so knowing
when you end a cut is it basically
exclusively dictated by how you're
feeling both in terms of you know how
you feel about your progress and how you
are currently feeling in the moment as
someone who's on a diet so uh a lot of
times people are people will ask like do
I need to do maintenance phases in
between to make the cuts successful and
the answer to that is no but there could
be very good reasons to do maintenance
phases along the way when someone goes
from an energy deficit into a bit of a
maintenance phase whether that's one
week or two weeks or 12 weeks just
getting into neutral energy balance can
do a lot of really positive things you
know subjectively you can feel a lot
better more energetic it can give you a
little boost in your exercise your
activity level you know it might help
your your hunger levels
um uh calm down a little bit there can
be a lot of nice things that occur
during a maintenance phase that
basically allow you to metaphorically
recharge your battery so then you can
re-initiate fat loss uh just from a
place where you're feeling really up for
the task and ready for another you know
a lot of people kind of treat it in
phases right where you you do a
successful fat loss phase you say okay
I'm gonna kind of it you know I'm a
little bit psychologically fatigued from
dieting I'm kind of in Terms of
Lifestyle sick of having such a low
calorie Target uh physiologically I feel
like a maintenance phase would do me
some good at that point people take some
time take a break you know a little
maintenance phase and then when they
feel ready to to really dig in for
another Fat Loss phase they dive right
back in so that that's a very
justifiable way to go but in terms of
when the whole process is over and you
say okay I've arrived you know fat loss
is done now we're maintaining long term
that's that's completely dependent on
your goals and preferences you know so
people go into a fat loss phase for a
lot of different reasons sometimes it's
related to Performance sometimes it's to
achieve a particular aesthetic look
sometimes it's too
make progress with regards to some
cardio metabolic risk factor like
someone might say I'm going to cut until
my blood sugar gets to this or my my you
know blood pressure gets to that so
there's a lot of different reasons to do
a fat loss phase or to pursue that type
of goal and therefore there are a lot of
different metrics that would allow
someone to determine that you know what
right now it's time to discontinue so uh
no reason is more justifiable than any
other it could be any number of reasons
and one one reason would be you know
what I thought I wanted to get down to
230 but I'm at 2 45 and I feel excellent
and that's great and that's a completely
justifiable reason to say all right
we're ready to move on to the next phase
so there's no hard number that says when
a cut should be over and there's really
no guideline about you know when
maintenance phases should be done or how
long they have to be
absolutely
um let's see
should I should I take a a more recent
or an older question in the chat what do
you think Drex uh whatever whatever's on
your heart all right uh
[Music]
okay so uh I'll just address a very
quick app related one from Jay Brody uh
he says on the new update you can't see
the current rate anymore on the trend
weight page was that intentional how do
you know if you're on target uh I
thought it was good to see that to
prevent to aggressively uh bulking or
cutting and uh I got something to show
you for the camera so uh you UJ are
probably on either 1.5.0 or 1.5.1 right
now if you're on
1.5.2 on the weight Trend page you
should get all something that looks like
what I am about to show the camera
right now for the audio audience
um there's a really interesting scene
developing Greg is holding his phone up
to the camera
and uh yeah very good Greg okay
[Music]
okay
so hopefully that was visible I could
not see my screen as I was holding that
up yeah in 1.5.2 uh all of those Trends
and even more are there so uh yeah you
can you can uh keep track of things over
even more time scales than ever before
cool I've got two very important things
to point out uh number one according to
Beth William Shatner filmed an entire
movie in the Esperanto language
good very cool good job Bill oh and
someone else mentioned Esperanto started
before the 90s I'm aware uh if you'll
roll the tape I said Esperanto got big
in the 90s it's never been popular but
its peak of popularity was in in the
Halcyon Days of the 90s uh so yes I I am
aware that Esperanto did start before
then another thing I wanted to point out
I mentioned my arch nemesis Eric Helms I
did not know that he would be dropping
it
we know that this is the real Eric Helms
he said he called us gents that's Helms
that that is that is a Helms thing yeah
that's true that is not fake so um uh I
just wanted to say uh Dr Helms the great
Dr Helms an esteemed researcher a top
level Fitness professional just the
utmost respect that I have for him uh
and it's an honor that he said that we
are his third favorite podcast of all
time because I'm for I'm sure the first
two are his uh knowing his personality
and the kind of human he is you know I
didn't even know he had a is there a
3dmj podcast yeah I think so cool yeah
I like I I say this not as a bit at all
I can I don't listen to any Fitness
podcasts so I I didn't mean that as as a
slight to uh the good doctor Helms or
3dmj or the concept of Fitness podcasts
I'm just uh incredibly out of the loop
yeah ooh here's a good one a little bit
of General Nutrition satiety
Greg you know satiety
does the literature support the idea
that uh satiety cues change when gaining
or losing weight and Greg uh what have
your experience has been with changes in
satiety on your journey
um I I would start you know before we we
get your personal Journey
um you know there's definitely some
pretty pronounced changes that occur
with hunger and satiety regulation that
are responsive to both short-term and
long-term energy availability
um we had a when you look at satiety it
it can become a very complex thing uh
but it can also lend itself to some very
very simple guidelines which I find to
be really fascinating uh so for example
what I'm getting at is you know we had a
guest article in the mass research
review a couple years back
um written by a you know someone who's
really into neuroscience and done a lot
of research in that area and was talking
about the the really complex interplay
of systems that regulate hunger and
satiety in terms of just the brain
structures so you know aside from just
like food characteristics and and
dieting and things like that but the
neurophysiological integration of
satiety control is very very fascinating
and absolutely very susceptible to
alteration based on both short-term and
long-term uh modifications and energy
availability so you know extreme
examples fasting for a few days very
pronounced dangers and hunger and
satiety
relationships and management losing and
gaining considerable amounts of weight
very very pronounced changes as well but
it's so funny because you look at some
of the guidelines that come from it and
it's simple stuff it's like if you're
struggling with you know really low
satiety High Hunger basic things eating
foods with low energy density uh
preferably below like 1.5 or 2
kilocalories per gram and you know what
that's basically meaning foods that have
take up a lot of space on your plate
they have a lot of water usually a lot
of fiber content per serving
um you know those types of foods help
fill up your belly that's a positive
thing because the the actual acute
distension of you know the the pressure
on the the stomach does matter
um eating slowly that that affects the
old in [ __ ] response the Gip glp one
all of that stuff yeah so uh eating
things with harder textures and you
might be wondering why would that matter
it's because it slows you down you have
to chew more if there's harder texture
and eating slower and more mindfully
causes you not just to give your satiety
signals an opportunity to respond to
energy intake but also there is some
some research indicating that just
spending more time with that food and
paying more attention to the flavors the
Aromas the texture the smell that seems
to almost modulate satiety responses in
a way that appears to be related to
memory and cognition so satiety is is
really fascinating there are all these
different uh nuanced inputs that
regulate it but in many cases the the
take-home points are actually quite
intuitive but Greg what have you
experienced with satiety so uh
I think one of my issues in general is
that I don't think I'm particularly
responsive to society cues
um
I rarely feel particularly hungry and I
also rarely feel particularly full uh
but I also
just really enjoy food and I enjoy the
sensation of eating which is why I think
when I'm not tracking and left my own
devices I just gradually gain weight
um but yeah like I I don't feel any more
ish any more or less issues with satiety
now than I did when I when I started my
cut so yeah uh which I think based on
the literature is probably atypical but
yeah yeah I think I'm like an in under
responder to satiety cues so if I could
share a uni well it sounds unique but it
isn't
um in an odd scenario that happens with
uh so I back in the day I did
competitive bodybuilding uh two sport
professional athlete but I don't want to
bring a lot of attention to that I don't
want that to be the whole point of the
podcast you don't you don't want
everyone who refers to you to add the
Epitaph the Bo Jackson a bodybuilding
correct I I really don't want that to
occur so everyone please stop sending me
those messages but after comp petitions
it's not that unusual for competitors to
be in a position where because there's
this massive dysregulation of both
satiety related regulation but also just
psychological factors of food intake
a lot of times after the final
competition of a year you'll see
physique athletes who are in this very
odd position that's difficult to explain
you kind of have to feel it and you have
to be there
but you're eating food and you have
filled your stomach and you're like I am
like I can tell that eating more food is
not in my best interest I'm gonna feel
like [ __ ] I already feel like [ __ ]
because I've eaten too much and yet you
have this desire to continue eating that
isn't even purely hedonic it's not just
like oh I like the taste of food I'd
like to taste more but it's this weird
thing where you're like I know that I am
not hungry right now I'm actually quite
full and yet for some reason my satiety
signals are not telling me to
discontinue and I still feel a
non-hedonic urge to eat that isn't
hunger or that isn't uh yeah that isn't
hungers it's a very strange situation
but like the reason I bring it up is it
gets to the most extreme scenario of
like how weird and wacky can satiety
regulation get disrupted with major
changes in body composition
and yeah there's this weird situation
you can get into and in that specific
scenario that is immensely difficult to
describe and
I I think it's just a a biological
response drilled into our basic code as
humans that it's like I don't care about
hedonic stuff or hunger you need to eat
because you're like four and a half
percent body fat and you're gonna die
soon if you don't eat yeah um but yeah
satiety just gets so weird when you get
down to those low body fat levels yeah I
I can't relate I know nothing about that
it's odd but but it's repeatable and
another thing that's interesting is and
this is getting way off topic but
something that I I think people will be
like morbidly fascinated with
I've talked to more than a few
bodybuilders I wonder if there's
research on this I'm not certain who
basically display I think they might
have mentioned this in the Minnesota
Minnesota starvation experiment almost
like uh Scavenging behaviors where
people will start to just kind of go to
the grocery store and hang out and just
check out what's going on in the aisles
and maybe even get some things that they
don't plan to eat for several months and
I've even heard of people hoarding like
utensils and cooking supplies and saying
like oh in four months boy am I going to
use this spatula like yeah it gets it
gets very odd psychologically as a
appreciator of the sport of bodybuilding
I have to say the more I learn about it
specifically from like competitors
really relaying their experience the
more it just seems like the most
deranged sport in the world like I I
don't know why anyone does it
you know that's but it's also cool it's
it's an in yeah that that's a whole
podcast unto itself is what is this and
why yeah yeah
all right uh so here here's a personal
one from the bees do you guys have any
sports related goals road to the stage
platform have you or your or have your
perspectives and priorities changed over
the years uh so yeah we we no longer do
the road to the stage or road to the
platform segments on the stronger by
science podcast we're trying to trying
to trim it down make it a tight zvelt
package uh and just kind of getting into
the content quicker so for example our
last episode was a very tight two and a
half hours so we're making great
progress It's as tight as it could have
been given the amount of content I will
say
um
but yeah yeah so uh sport related goals
so my uh my current and ongoing weight
loss is
I wouldn't say it's with sport goals in
mind but it is with kind of like
physical kind of athletic related goals
in mind
um
I so I'm not uh particularly interested
anymore and necessarily trying to be the
best power lifter I can possibly be
um and I find that I train best lift
best and I'm just just stronger at a at
a higher body fat level which is one of
the reasons I've been larger for most of
the most of the last decade like like on
a pure physiological basis like
fat tissue doesn't have contractile
properties but like I'm I'm just like
way stronger at like 25 plus body fat
than I am when I'm lean I don't know why
but uh that's been my very consistent
repeatable experience me too uh sweet
yeah so anyway I'm not I'm not living
that same life anymore
um
and essentially there are a lot of
things that I that I like to do that I
do better like essentially I'm strongest
when I'm larger and everything else is
better when I'm smaller
um like it's just easier to move around
a lot without getting tired or winded
um I'm a lot more explosive I'm a lot
faster and uh like I love playing
basketball and so in terms of just like
acute goals like I'm I'm not really
planning on joining like a competitive
league or anything like that but I'm
still 30. I still have what I'm going to
consider another decade of Youth ahead
of me
um who knows how honest I'm being with
myself but that's that's the way I'm
approaching it uh and so just for like
pickup ball I I want to get to the point
where I can physically dominate people
the way that I like to be able to which
like I I'm I'm always going to be strong
enough to to do what I need to do on the
court but I don't have as fast of a
first step as I would like to have and
as I previously had and I don't have the
verticality to my game that I used to
um so I I want to get those two things
back and in terms of just like a kind of
marker that I'm working towards
um I used to be able to barely dunk if I
got the perfect alley-oop
um and I I want to I want to get to
where I can like very convincingly dunk
like not do anything acrobatic but just
you know convincingly and without any
sort of fanfare just be able to get on a
court and if I get an open fast break
just be able to very reliably put it
down
um
so yeah more than anything that's that's
probably my my biggest uh uh physical
goal and and the thing that motivates me
for the weight loss more than anything
else
um and in terms of how my priorities
have changed over time
you know I'm I'm uh just just trying
like I used to be all about Just Sports
and being a general athlete
um and being physically capable of being
really good at a lot of things and then
I spent a little over a decade really
focusing on one thing that I wanted to
be good at which was just being as
strong as possible and so now I'm I'm
going back to my roots uh and and trying
to become more of more of a generalist
again yeah
you should uh what year was it that
Vince Carter had that crazy dunk contest
was that 2004
I don't know I'll I'll search while
you're answering now that we're doing
more stuff on YouTube you should get to
the point where you can just recreate
that shot for shot and we'll put it up
and people enjoy it it was two thousand
yeah I I didn't think it was o4 well but
yeah you can't blame me he he was still
playing like a year ago that is true
that is which is crazy dude he was
he was still good too I I think I think
he still had like a positive plus minus
his last year yeah uh but for me
um
you know I this is an interesting
question so like I don't really have any
desire to do anything hyper competitive
at the moment
um but over you know there's no question
that over the last couple years I've
been really really really focused on
making a lot of like content and doing a
lot of coaching and stuff like that like
I think I've been heavily focused on
work in a way that's detracted from my
general
enthusiasm for virtually everything
outside of work including training uh
and my my enthusiasm for training really
took a hit because I had some ongoing
like back and hip issues that I've
really really struggled with and I use
the past tense there for no reason at
all like it's it's not it's not in a
good place yet but
um
I do think that it is time to
really tighten things up with my
training I'm actually feeling as
motivated as I ever have to get back to
a spot where I feel you know I'm not
like going to compete in anything but I
want to get back to a spot where I feel
very very very proud of my overall
General strength level conditioning
level and physique so like you said kind
of an all-around kind of deal where I
feel very strong very capable from a
cardio respiratory perspective and just
feel like you know what this shirt I'm
making it look really good right now
it's been a while since I really felt
that way deep down and it's a cool
feeling when you get there and I yeah I
think in the next year or so I'm very
enthusiastic about getting back to that
spot where I just have a a really high
level of confidence in my strength and
uh you know just general physical
capacity sounds good man yeah
I've mentioned this before but we should
we should play we should play some
sports together put some shots up you
played baseball I think there's a a
field nearby we can have like a little
Home Run Derby or something like that
that might be fun so I have played some
pickleball I've thought about
um
there was I was thinking about getting
into recreational sport leagues like I
would love to play flag football I'd be
all about that
um but yeah I I definitely think that
getting back into sports would be a lot
of fun sweet
uh let's see were there were there any
questions you were eyeing
um
not not specifically but I've been in my
own world answering that previous one I
have to look around here yeah that's
that's totally fine uh let's see
uh Pickin Chang asks uh training
question thoughts on three minutes rest
for hypertrophy uh that's great
um the the two issues you can run into
when talking about rest intervals for uh
for either a strength or hypertrophy
perspective is that if rest intervals
get too short it can compromise
performance on the next set which is
unavoidable to some extent like even if
you're resting 10 minutes between sets
if you're really pushing sets hard
performance is going to drop off over
time but if you're not resting long
enough that you know can accelerate the
process and potentially Downstream of
that or potentially just from other
factors
um we there's there's reasonably
reliable research showing that if you're
not resting long enough between sets
you're probably leaving some hypertrophy
on the table so uh at least looking at
like two or three minutes of rest
between sets the other issue you can run
into is just resting too long
um which isn't a problem per se except
from an efficiency perspective like
you're not really getting anything for
it but it just makes your workouts take
longer so if I were
if I were to give kind of like a
one-size-fits all how long should I rest
between set's answer it would probably
be around three minutes per set
um
for a slightly more nuanced answer you
can probably go shorter than that for
kind of like single joint accessory
lifts may not be a bad idea to go longer
than that for compound exercises
especially lower body exercises
especially if you're reasonably strong
and especially if you're doing moderate
or higher rep ranges
um but yeah somewhere around three
minutes seems to get the job done if you
go to the gym and you kind of have a
timer on you and you're like man I'm
resting three minutes between sets and
that feels like forever and I I feel
like I'm just not using my time
efficiently
um then something you could try just to
use your time a little bit more
efficiently is a superset approach where
you either go with a Agonist antagonist
superset so that means basically just
muscles that do opposite things so maybe
do like like knee extensions and
hamstring curls like knee flexion knee
extension uh or like the classic buys
and tries super sets uh you know binge
press and Rose overhead press pull up
something like that
so Agonist antagonist super sets there's
some research suggesting that that
actually improves performance that
you'll like do better for the exercises
you're training if you do an Agonist
antagonist superset versus just straight
sets
that's an area where honestly like the
research says oh it might improve
performance I don't buy it uh this could
be my n equals one experience I've never
noticed that like if if I superset bench
press with rose binge is still fine but
I find that if anything performance is
is a little bit lower instead of being
maintained or uh improved but the the
difference shouldn't be particularly
large and that should be a way to use
your time a little bit more effectively
or like an Agonist distant super set
um that's probably not the right
terminology but you know like uh pairing
like an upper body exercise with the
lower body exercise just something
that's not training the same Prime
movers also shouldn't compromise
performance too much but we'll let you
kind of increase the density of your
training
um
or you could
find something to do between sets to
like pursue some other goal you have
that wouldn't necessarily detract from
your lifting so for example if you're
trying to improve like hip flexion
Mobility or something like that uh and
you're currently doing pull-ups you know
you could do a set of pull-ups and then
like stretch your hamstrings for a
minute or two between sets uh which
would be using that time productively
but in a way that's not going to detract
from the exercises you're doing to
ensure that you're you're resting as
long as you probably should so um yeah
those are my thoughts about uh three
minutes of rest between sets for
hypertrophy good stuff I've got a couple
that I want to address one of them is
going to be very quick here so question
from lift stronger uh I'm just so
tickled by this
the question is any plans to include
protein quality scores in a future
update so people who eat a variety of
incomplete protein sources can gauge how
they may need to adjust their diet to
meet protein requirements Now Greg
you're the only human in the world right
now who knows why I'm so tickled by this
Greg and I recorded uh our next podcast
episode just minutes before we sat down
for this uh LIVE edition
and that is literally the the main focal
point of a segment that will be in the
next uh Stronger by science podcast
episode so we are switching over to that
Monday publishing
um schedule but if you keep an eye on
the YouTube page I think some of the
segments are going to trickle out on on
Wednesdays and Fridays before it goes up
on Monday
um next Monday not this Monday but
anyway keep an eye on on the podcast in
the YouTube page we're gonna have a like
40 minute segment exactly on that
question more or less uh the short
version is
we're always interested in putting in
analytics that are informative and
actionable I'm not saying that we would
never put that in from an analytics
perspective but I don't currently view
that as a high priority item because as
I discuss in that that longer segment I
think that focusing on really small
differences in protein quality scores
within the context of an entire diet
I don't think that that effort is
fruitful or particularly worthwhile in
in the podcast episode I I talk about
how the research generally indicates if
you're mating meeting some very basic
General guidelines for protein intake
with the most important one being total
protein intake for the day and the
second most important being how you
distribute that throughout the day any
small differences in protein quality
scores have very minimal impacts on
things like muscle protein synthesis
measured acutely and essentially
negligible impacts on hypertrophy over
time within some very specific uh
constraints that I mentioned in the
podcast but the the short version is for
most people worrying about protein
quality scores in a balanced diet is
really not a worthwhile Endeavor so
there's not a a high priority or sense
of urgency for getting that particular
analytic into the app
um
yeah I think that's all I had to say on
oh one thing I should mention though is
like
you know a lot of times people will get
really caught up in in protein quality
scores and and say like I think I'm
eating too many plant-based proteins or
too many low quality proteins the
typical omnivorous diet
um you know is usually a relatively even
mixture of high quality and low quality
animal based and plant-based sources and
there's really no evidence to suggest
that adjusting your protein quality
sources within the context of that diet
is really going to move the needle at
all in terms of promoting strength and
hypertrophy over time
the other question I wanted to answer is
hiding from me did you have one that you
wanted to mention uh
uh sure
um
um yeah here here's a good uh kind of
retrospective question since this is the
macro Factor one year anniversary
looking back on the first year do you
have any regrets or things you would
have done differently if given the
chance to redo it all
um
and that is a difficult question to
answer I would say because there are
so you know it's one of those things
where
you can learn a lot or or just kind of
like know a lot from like
you know uh uh like I don't want to use
this phrase but like book learning
basically and you can go into something
with a game plan and a set of
assumptions about how to tackle things
uh that you know you will understand the
strengths and weaknesses of the approach
you took better uh once those plans
actually
come to pass in the real world
um and so like there there are there are
things we would have done differently I
believe if we just like took ourselves
from this moment in a time machine and
went back in time uh you know to to take
lessons we've learned now and reapply
them in the past on the other hand I
don't know that that's a fair standard
to hold oneself to
um because I don't think we made really
that I can think of any like large
noteworthy mistakes or unforced errors
that we should have foresawed
um so like like for example
um
the new design system for the food
logger for the dashboard revamp and for
the the forthcoming
um like food log and and day in review
and food detail view Pages
um you know if if we would have had all
of the user feedback a year ago that we
have today we would have made different
choices and just launched with the
current design system
um yeah but it's also like if you go
back in time a year ago there's no
[ __ ] way we could have known any of
that
um so yeah like like honestly and this
may sound intemperate to say
um
I think I think we made the right
decisions with the information and
knowledge we had at the time of making
those decisions so uh and like I
mentioned to start this podcast like
things have gone
peculiarly smoothly
um so yeah I I don't know that I that I
would have changed anything honestly for
a minute you sounded like that that
documentary The Fog of War when it was
like listen we we made the best
decisions we could make with the
information that we had okay
that's what you sounded like is that
like a Iraq War documentary I think it
was uh McNamara McNamara oh yeah okay
but uh anyway just uh an aside there no
I I the way I like to view this kind of
thing is I mean like you said we've had
this Super Active development road map
where we are constantly making updates
and changes and improvements and so of
course you can't look back and say oh
day one that's exactly how it was
supposed to be we would never change a
thing like just the fact that we are so
actively continuing to take feedback and
incorporate it you know of course yeah
like we have learned a lot in the first
year and it's all been very productive
and constructive uh learning
opportunities but I I think the the the
most straightforward way to look at a
question like that is like
if you could just hit the reset button
and start over would you take that
opportunity and just start fresh
completely differently you know because
I I don't like to view like individual
decisions in a vacuum because I just
don't think that's a realistic way to
view them I mean like a an alternate
question that I've been asked is is kind
of like an icebreaker in like certain
events over time is like if if you could
go back and like correct one mistake
you've made like what what would it be
and like I've certainly [ __ ] up and
made plenty of mistakes in my life but
it's also like
I don't know man shit's going pretty
well so yeah uh
overall I'm content and if I would have
made some other decision maybe you know
[ __ ] butterfly wings and Chaos Theory
and all that [ __ ] like who who knows
like maybe maybe I would have wound up
in a worse place overall and that's
you know that that's kind of how I feel
about this question yeah you know I I
wouldn't say that 100
of like like if like I said if we had a
time machine could go back knowing what
we know now we would have made some
different decisions but also like things
are going great and who knows if things
would have turned out differently if we
took a different approach so yeah yeah I
mean I just totally cut you off and I'm
I apologize for that it's okay that's
why we have a rigid hierarchy in terms
of hosting and co-hosting but I would
yeah to kind of look at this from a
different perspective I would go back
and just say like
you know
when it comes to regrets it's like on
day one did we know everything of course
not you know because that that's not
feasible when you're trying a new thing
starting a new project
um but year one in terms of uh the work
that Lindsay and Corey and Rebecca have
done in terms of the way the app has
changed over time in terms of the uh
remarkable support from users uh I mean
I I wouldn't change a thing because I've
just been it succeeded my expectations
in every single area that I just
mentioned
um so yeah I mean we didn't know
everything on day one but year one has
been you know I just have a lot of
gratitude because I think it's gone
exceptionally well and I'm super
thankful for that both for the people
within our team and also just the the
users out there everyone who has been
part of this process uh everyone who has
contributed to the macro Factor
communities provided feedbacks supported
us by using the app uh yeah it's been a
really incredible year yeah
um big big change of pace
Levy's fit asks anything evidence-based
about hair loss growing here preserving
Hair
Etc uh and I mostly wanted to answer
this because I apologize Levy's fit but
we are the worst people you could have
possibly asked this question to
um I think I speak for both of us when I
say we are both not only perfectly
content with hair loss but at least for
me I actively embrace it and look
forward to it I like to have the most
minimal personal care and grooming uh
system possible like if if you go back
and look at uh like the podcast archive
you'll notice I average about three
haircuts per year
um which is just because like I don't
want to deal with my hair and I don't
mind how it looks when it when it's
short I don't mind how it looks when it
gets longer once it starts like getting
in my eyes or like on my neck I'm like
okay this is [ __ ] annoying let's just
cut it all off
um
so man if I like what if if I could wake
up tomorrow and just not have a single
hair left on the top of my head and
never have to think about it again that
would be perfect for me so
um
anyway I've not looked into research on
uh regrowing or preserving hair because
that is uh actively counter to my
interests
yeah I have taken a look at the men in
my family uh
and it's not looking promising in terms
of
hair prospects for the future for me uh
I've also been looking at my own
scalp and that also
presents some uh some unfavorable
feedback visually
so yeah I I have resigned myself to
being a person
um who has what is unfortunately a you
know
yeah it's it only affects you know a
small percentage of men between a third
and a half I think but but I do believe
that I am deep in the throes of
androgenic alopecia and uh as you said
Greg I don't think we're the right
people to ask for that because uh you're
probably gonna lose your hair right I
hope so yeah I definitely am and I'm
just along for the ride I I'm I'm not as
excited about it as you but I I I'm very
neutral toward it like I shave my head
anyway so I'm like whatever I'll I'll
shave it shorter
um but yeah I haven't looked into any of
it and uh you know I I totally
understand people who
have an interest in delaying or
reversing hair loss I totally understand
that perspective uh and for those
individuals I hope that they are able to
find effective strategies for what
they're looking for but for me I'm not
not super concerned about it and so I
haven't looked into it because you only
have so many hours in a day that makes
sense
um
yeah this I don't know how
evidence-based this is but I will say
like
I I overstated myself slightly before I
have looked into this a little bit in
the like the medication you would take
for preserving hair uh like like uh
what's it called finasteride or whatever
yeah the five Alpha re reductase
Inhibitors
um
those I don't know the extent to which
this is causal but there's at least some
um like cross-sectional research I
believe linking them to potentially
increased rates of cognitive decline
which uh concerns me more than losing my
hair does uh the things that there seem
to be at least like a little tiny bit of
research on
um that
um that probably come without many if
any side effects are apparently uh
peppermint extract and Menthol uh
stimulate hair follicles to uh to regrow
hair
um
and I mean I guess they'd make your head
smell good so you could you could
potentially look into that but that
that's not a topic I've done uh a bunch
of deep research on yeah
um there's a question I'd like to very
briefly address here someone was asking
about uh for like long-term muscle gain
uh whether a preferred approach is to do
kind of repeated sequences of you know
relatively aggressive bulking and
cutting phases versus just kind of
settling in for a nice slow steady
long-term bulking phase
um that's something that I've actually
gotten a few questions about over the
last few weeks so it's kind of top of
mind uh my personal preference if you if
there's no rush by which you need to
like very promptly gain muscle or very
promptly get lean for a particular
purpose like a competition an event
whatever the case is my general approach
my general preference is to do a nice
long slow steady bulking phase the
reason I prefer that is because I like
to try to match my rate of weight gain
in a bulk to a realistic rate of muscle
gain and as a person who is not using
exogenous anabolics
that rate of muscle gain is not super
you know especially at my phase of
someone who's been Lifting for a long
time I'm not going to gain like 35
pounds of muscle in the blink of an eye
not with that attitude yeah look at me
so Health psychology research right I'm
failing uh but you know realistically I
I try to look at it and say okay what
what is the a realistic amount of muscle
I can gain over the next year and I try
to tailor my my rate of weight gain to
that and usually a bulking phase for me
at the absolute bare minimum is going to
be six months usually going to be closer
to a year just so I can do it slow and
steady because the benefit there is
you're not necessarily inviting a high
degree of unwanted fat gain in the
process and you know if you're
comfortable with with an appreciable
amount of fat gain then by all means you
can accelerate the process for sure but
you know I I see a lot of folks who say
well you have to do Balkan cutting
Cycles because
you know a lot of times people say
slow bulks are so hard to track over
time like the the Surplus is so small
and the rate of weight gain is so slow
you know it's very difficult to
logistically track that so you have to
do this rapid weight gain and rapid
weight cut and rapid weight gain and
rapid weight cut and with the type of
technologies that are available for
monitoring things over time I no longer
find that to be a compelling argument to
to be totally honest I think with you
know even if you're not using macro
factor with very straightforward uh
efforts toward tracking your body weight
over time smoothing out the noise and
the data with very basic soft you know
Google sheet Excel I think it's more
feasible Than People suggest to track a
nice slow bulk over time
and so I think the the that argument
that you need to therefore do really
rapid weight gain and really rapid
weight Cuts I I don't personally uh
subscribe to that perspective yeah
uh and also I mean you would know this
better than me but doesn't the evidence
at least seem to suggest that if a large
Surplus is more efficacious than a small
Surplus for building muscle the the net
difference is probably pretty small yeah
I mean we don't have a lot of good
evidence about you know what an ideal
Surplus would be all we can really do is
I mean it's very clear that if you
overshoot it uh precipitous fat gain is
sure to follow uh unless you have unless
you're of a particular metabolic
phenotype such that you know you you
know really aggressively increase your
non-exercise activity level uh or
thermogenesis uh so some people do have
some kind of resistance to Fat gain that
appears to be innate
um and they have a little more wiggle
room or more cushion there but we really
don't know the optimal uh size of a
surplus for weight gain but what we can
do is say okay well what's the energy
cost of all the processes going into
this and based on those energy costs it
looks like you probably don't need a
particularly large caloric Surplus to
maximize or nearly maximize the benefits
of of being in a surplus for for
hypertrophy
makes sense to me all right uh let's see
so Adam Conrad has a question about uh
like adding rdas from for micronutrients
into the app
um Adam once uh once this is done go
back and listen to the start of this
live q a I addressed a question related
to that but uh in short that is uh that
is definitely in the plans for this
upcoming year
[Music]
um
Brooks swinerton uh asks what sort of
recovery window should you aim for
between workout days for maximum
hypertrophy and my answer to that is
that it is
very very contingent on what the details
of those workouts look like and you can
make a lot of recovery windows work for
you uh depending on what your training
looks like so uh if you want to go for a
higher frequency approach where you're
training a particular muscle group with
maybe only 48 hours between sessions
like you know if you wanted to hit back
Monday Wednesday and Friday
um
generally that's going to necessitate
lower per session volumes and at least
for one or two of those sessions you can
still stimulate the muscles but you
probably want to not push them quite as
hard so there's adequate time to recover
so you know probably not training to
failure in all of those sessions and you
know like you're
um
you you have to kind of go into the gym
with a well-defined plan and a bit of a
limiter so if you're the type of person
who your approach to hypertrophy
training is say like hey these are the
muscle groups I'm training in this
workout and I'm just gonna [ __ ]
clobber them in this session uh you
probably won't be able to get away with
uh 24 48 hours between sessions of
training that muscle group uh that would
probably be more amenable to a training
frequency of once or twice per week with
maybe up to a week of recovery between
workouts for a particular muscle or at
least 72 to 96 hours
um
so yeah like if if the details of your
training program are amenable to a
higher training frequency so a little
bit lower volumes per workout for the
muscles you're training not going to
failure quite as frequently you could
train a muscle group three four times
per week with just 48 hours between
sessions on average or if you want to be
quite conservative with per session
training volume you could theoretically
train the same muscle every day although
uh the marginal benefits of doing so are
are probably smaller non-existent so not
saying you should do that just that that
you could set up your training such that
you could
um but yeah like if if you're if you're
the type of person who who just really
wants to hammer the muscles you're
training for a particular workout then
you're looking at training frequencies
of like once or twice per per muscle
group per week which kind of lends
itself just naturally to uh rest periods
between training that that muscle of at
least 72 hours
good stuff
all right I wanted to answer a quick
question here from Matt B question was
is the new podcast episode this month
this Monday or the following Monday the
answer is the following Monday so today
is Friday the 16th which means Monday is
what
the 19th
is that right
16 17 18 19. that seems very plausible
yeah yeah it's it's the 19th so what's
the one after that uh the one out 26 is
the 26. so yeah the the next full
podcast episode is going to be released
on the 26th but
this upcoming week on Wednesday and on
Friday we are I think putting videos on
the YouTube channel so like little uh
segments from that upcoming episode I
believe that's what we're gonna
accomplish uh cool so yeah
um let's see any other good ones to get
to here
uh I thought I saw one but they always
just sneak away when I go back and look
for them
yeah uh let's see
so
I
I'm going to answer this question by jfb
who I think has asked this at least
twice in the chat seems insistent so uh
probably definitely worth getting to how
does macro Factor account for scale
weight increases from the amount of food
you're eating in the beginning of a gain
phase so
um
I'm going to put a link in the chat from
uh the macro Factor knowledge base that
should that should help clarify this but
essentially the the weight trending
approach we use is uh is back looking
and also doesn't
doesn't price in uh gains in weight like
automatically essentially so you know if
you um
if you were say at maintenance
previously and you weighed uh 165 or
something like that and you decide hey
I'm going to shift into a surplus I'm
going to start eating more and maybe
your scale weight jumps up four or five
pounds from the start of the week to the
end of the week just because there's
more you know food contents in your
stomach glycogen levels are higher more
fluid of retention uh Etc
uh
basically macro Factor won't look at
that and be like oh [ __ ] this person
gained five pounds this week they're in
a surplus of like 2 500 calories per day
let's let's slash the calories the
approach we use essentially if you do
have
notable fluctuations in weight that are
sustained those increases are priced in
gradually and so the full effect of that
five pounds that you gained in the span
of a week so like since you're not
actually in a surplus resulting in five
pounds of weight gain per week every
week
essentially like you know it it will
jump initially and then start gradually
trending up from there and that initial
increase you saw will be gradually
priced in over about three weeks give or
take
um which is uh far more appropriate so
you don't get like Herky jerky you know
multi hundred calorie increases in your
targets week to week as you're adjusting
to a new Diet phase
um
but yeah like I feel like that's about
all I can say without just like fully
divulging how we do it but the
um the the link from the macro Factor
knowledge base should uh like especially
the the images in it should help uh
explain what's going on and how how we
do kind of like gradually ease you into
those phases and uh account for like
rapid but sustained fluctuations
good stuff I've got one I want to answer
here from Heather P very quick one uh
why do I see some Fitness and
bodybuilding competitors cut Dairy for
fat loss is there any research to
support this or is it bro science
um so
basically uh this is a thing that became
popular in the bodybuilding world I
would file it under
either a Bro Science or just kind of a
misinterpretation of what's going on so
I I think some people got into that uh
mindset that you cut Dairy simply
because there are other protein sources
that offer uh fewer calories per gram of
protein I think that's a popular thing
in the bodybuilding world is immediately
when you switch over to a cut especially
like the old school bodybuilding world
it's like what are the leanest protein
sources possible so minimal fat content
minimal carb content and even if you go
for lower fat Dairy there's still
usually depending on the the exact food
there's usually some carbohydrate
content that comes with it so um back in
back in the day the bodybuilders it was
like protein was just coming from whey
isolate and you know skinless chicken
breast and like the leanest fish you
could imagine you know that was kind of
the old school way of doing it so part
of it might just be a simplified way of
reducing calories with about actually
putting that name to it other folks I do
suspect
might have minor intolerances to Dairy
and just have some bloating that occurs
when they consume Dairy and so I think
folks might have noticed that when they
cut Dairy that bloating goes away
acutely and they say oh wow I look you
know leaner and I feel better Etc so
this is how I'm going to cut from now on
so I think it's largely an issue of just
misattributing what it What role Dairy
is really having in terms of acutely
inducing some bloating in susceptible
individuals not in everybody and then
also just kind of the extra calories
that come with dairy sources of protein
so there's absolutely no research to
indicate that you need to cut Dairy for
fat loss it absolutely can stay in there
and support uh very very effective fat
loss progress as you go
um there was one other one here oh
can we do one about D loads sure
so uh someone asked to quit there were
actually a couple different questions
about deloades which is why I wanted to
address it uh Leslie Wong asked the most
open-ended version which is how do you
guys like to approach d-loads
um and so that there are a couple ways
that I like to do it
um
I've experimented with a few different
ways over the years uh back in the day I
would keep my volume relatively similar
but just drop my loads to like half or
like 60 percent of what I used to do
uh that was fine but I felt it was
tedious and annoying I didn't really
enjoy it because I was like I'm in the
gym just as long I'm just not enjoying
it having fun so then I started saying
well whatever I'm Gonna Keep the
intensity a little bit higher than that
but really dramatically cut the volume
and I would cut the volume down to like
you know way less than half you know
maybe even a third or a quarter of what
I usually do so I'd go in and it's not
like I'm doing like super heavy stuff
but heavy enough to keep it interesting
but just slashing my volume really
precipitously and in many cases
combining my workouts so instead of
going to the gym five days that week I
only have to drive over three days a
week or something like that nowadays
um I honestly have a tendency to just
let life handle deloads for me and what
I mean by that is I I don't I know that
some people are gonna
uh criticize me mercilessly for this I
don't really like to train when I travel
unless I'm traveling for like a fitness
conference and it's like an event for
everyone to train together you know if
I'm going on a vacation and it's like oh
I want to go like ski I don't want to
say well we got to find a mountain near
a gym or you know drive through 20
minutes of mountains to go find a gym
because I got to go do a workout I
prefer to just let my deloads fall when
I simply cannot get to the gym or don't
want to get to the gym for a week
and I'll generally just take a week off
or if I feel really compelled to I might
do some really light stuff push-ups
bands little you know pistol squats
stuff I can do with body weight or
minimal equipment but over the years as
my goals have changed and my just
general intensity level toward training
has changed uh I've taken a much more
laid back approach and just said like
you know when a good time to take a
deload is it's like when I have a
vacation or if I'm sick and I found that
the more that I train for like physique
Focus purposes you know it's if you're
training for like a power lifting
competition you might have to go or you
might feel compelled to get a little bit
more serious with how you arrange a
deload but if you're just like generally
training to be overall healthy fit and
have like you know a physique that suits
your goals in that case like you
probably don't need more than
maybe a few deloads a year and you might
get sick once or twice you might be out
of town once or twice and so for me
delos have just become something that
occurs rather than something I have to
proactively implement
yeah it's funny you say that that's uh
that's exactly where I'm at as well
um
yeah either for like instances where
going to the gym would just be very
inconvenient like if we're traveling if
we're seeing family whatever
um
or just like uh I mean you know this
about me during my most busy writing
week for Mass every month I just don't
go to the gym because I'm I'm working
from when I wake up to when I go to
sleep and uh going to the gym would just
mean less sleep and uh my sleep is
precious during those times yeah so uh
yeah my life just carves out a week
every month to deload regardless
um so yeah that's that's how I approach
it these days historically I gotta say I
I've never really been one for deloads
um
I
always at least thought that it was
something that I should do but it was
also the type of thing where
I I would just sort of like on a workout
to work out basis let how I was feeling
and how I was performing dictate how I
would train so essentially like if if I
was in need of a deload uh which you
know I I would figure out after the fact
I would go into the gym still planning
on lifting heavy and and getting my
volume in and whatnot and then I'd start
warming up I'd start putting weight on
the bar and like the weight's just going
to be moving the way they were supposed
to and I got pretty good at just
realizing like nope today is not my day
um and so not pushing the heavy stuff
quite as heavy as I typically would
um
try a back offset and like sometimes top
end strength wouldn't be there but like
volume work still felt great still
performed well
um and so that would just you know it
would just be like still a hard training
session but I just changed the focus of
it like yeah I don't have the top end
stuff in me today but like I can still
get a good workout in higher volume
stuff and that still feels good
if I do my first drop back set and it
also just didn't feel good I'd say oh
well
not today uh and you know I might do a
couple accessory sets of something and
then just leave yeah and uh if I pushed
myself too hard over like a period of
weeks I might have like four training
sessions in a row that went like that
and then what do you know now I just had
four pretty easy training sessions back
to back and then uh after that guess
what I feel strong again and uh just go
back to normal so yeah
um yeah from
taking like a fairly like intuitively
Auto regulated approach to training
um
D loads just kind of like naturally
happened when I needed them but they
they weren't something that I really
planned ahead of time or really had uh a
plan for how I would address them like
yeah basically for for the better part
of a decade if I was feeling strong I'd
lift heavy if I wasn't feeling strong
but you know the Reps were still there
felt productive then I'd still train
hard but just lighter
um and if that didn't feel good too it's
an easy day and just roll with the
punches yeah you know I didn't really
think about it that way but that is
something that I've always done
um and so I I think that that probably
is why I haven't felt the need to
specifically carve out a lot of time for
deloads is because yeah I do the same
form of like if it's not there I don't
force it and so I think that that
largely alleviates the need for very
formal week-long deloads if if you're
like yeah I kind of just phoned it in
for the last few workouts and just kind
of kept it easy it's essentially a small
deload yeah uh one other follow-up
question people had do you I don't
change my calorie intake during a deload
do you no yeah I like to just keep
things simple yeah
you see uh pack is in the uh in the
comments there yo what's up uh
no pack uh hypertrophy is not a
supplement that we sell not yet uh not
yet
um
let's see let's
uh
uh someone asked about
um so basically due to some stress and
time management challenges they couldn't
sleep well that's what's the minimum
sleep that we think they should get uh
to uh to make sure they're recovering
from training my personal answer is I
think there's a
somewhat considerable variability in
terms of how much sleep each individual
person needs and I think a good way to
find that out is by assessing exactly
how much you feel like [ __ ] with a given
amount of sleep uh you know so like me
and my girlfriend require very different
amounts of sleep I require less I don't
frame that as like a virtue and like
sometimes people are like oh sleeping a
lot is is not good but like then other
times people act like sleeping too
little is uh like you're you're short
changing yourself and cutting Corners
like I I think a good way to determine
how much sleep you need is to be try to
be as objective and possible and be
honest with yourself and figure out like
how how much sleep do you need to really
feel like you're at your best not just
physically but also cognitively
um for me it's seven hours uh if I
increase from seven to eight I don't
really notice too much from that if I
drop from seven to six I feel it in a
big way I I am useless if I get only six
hours of sleep for a continuous period
of time
yeah I so the the thing about poor sleep
is the effects are cumulative
um I I do think people have a tendency
to overly catastrophize one night of
either short sleep or poor poor quality
sleep
um
and as far as far as like training
performance goes like one night of poor
sleep doesn't really seem to do much if
anything
um
but then like a week of consistently
poor or shortened sleep uh certainly can
add up and and have deleterious effects
so yeah I think that a lot of it is just
kind of uh
a matter like you said of just assessing
on a personal level where you feel fine
and where you perform well
um but yeah also one thing I should add
is that um
there are
sleep is very tempting to reduce it down
to a single integer you know five hours
six hours seven hours eight hours
there's a lot more that goes into it in
terms of waking up feeling well rested
you know so I think that
in the quest to identify effective sleep
quantity don't lose sight of Sleep
Quality as well which can be harder to
keep an eye on but you know you you can
have two different nights of sleep or
you sleep seven hours and wake up
feeling dramatically different uh those
two nights and I think a lot of basic
sleep hygiene practices go a long way in
trying to make sure that the hours you
get are truly high quality hours of
sleep I agree uh do you wanna do you
want to look at wrapping it up soon yeah
I think probably probably one more and
we should be good to go right cool yeah
we're pushing two hours and just in
terms of Vibes in the room I feel like
both of us are losing steam a little bit
yeah um
so yeah or were there any like
particularly good ones that you would
like to end on
um you know I gotta be honest I I
covered most of the big ones that I
wanted to get to I'm struggling to think
of another one here were there any that
you had in mind hey people watching
right now if there's a burning question
currently on your mind drop it in the
chat we'll [ __ ] for like two or
three minutes and whatever the best
question is that comes in uh very soon
is is the one we'll end on well I can
[ __ ] about the fact I feel
personally attacked by the Sleep
questions because you know I was in a
very grave State a couple days ago yes
uh I pulled approximately an all-nighter
doing work stuff and just felt like
absolute garbage but today I think I am
finally
caught up on sleep and out of that
cumulative sleep debt
and today I almost felt like I almost
felt like euphoric you know what I mean
when you finally get caught up and
you're like oh this is what it feels
like to not be a zombie so
um very happy to be back in the sleeping
part of the the human Community glad to
hear it man uh oh here here's a fun a
fun one to end on by Fitness
who uh has been asking a lot of
questions I've been watching the chat
and I don't think we've answered any
from from them yet uh but they ask can
you both share can both of you guys
share a recipe which seems fun to me
what what have you been cooking recently
Eric
uh this is
you wanna know what I had today what did
you have today
um I had my pea based protein shake that
was one of my meals
and the other meal I made white rice and
I put chickpeas in it and a little bit
of soy sauce and a little bit of
teriyaki sauce it sounds good and that
that is
probably 85 percent of my diet over the
course of the week nice yeah so uh
there's your recipe make sure you you
tag me if you use it because that's
that's intellectual property so I'll
I'll give two uh one one I guess is more
of like a concept but it's what it's
what I'm currently doing for meal prep
and I gotta say it's great and the other
one is more for you than the chat but
it's it's a look ahead to an experiment
that I'm going to be trying tomorrow for
uh for tomorrow yes so uh first meal
prep related thing so uh I previously
experimented with using noodles as like
my primary carb source for meal prep
instead of rice or something similar and
the issue I ran into is that like you
can't you can't really prep ahead
noodles without them just getting like
too too soggy over time uh at least like
to an extent that I don't like and
um
I found that for whatever reason uh and
and so like the reason I wanted to go
with noodles is as you mentioned before
even omnivores get a fair bit of protein
from from non-animal sources uh and you
also had a mass article a while back
about how
um you know like minus the lysine
deficiency uh like wheat protein like
gluten is actually like a surprisingly
high quality protein Source I mean not
not necessarily based on like the like
quantitative metrics of like the scales
that are popularized but like in terms
of actual effects it does quite well
yeah yeah so
um one of the cool things about about
noodles is like previously my my go-to
carb Source was rice I would just cook a
[ __ ] ton of basmati rice and that would
be most of my carbs for the week uh but
like noodles have about twice as much
protein per unit of
like calories or carbs compared to rice
so I was like hey this would be a very
convenient way to keep my protein high
without having to consume quite as much
like meat or dairy or whatever else uh
you know it just gives me more
flexibility with what I want to do they
probably keep better as well right for
like over the course of the week you
know they say that cooking rice ahead is
dangerous from like a food safety
perspective
I don't
yeah apparent apparently uh if you cook
rice and like leave it in the fridge it
can like get infected with [ __ ] what
dude that's like most of my diet that is
that also like for most of my life has
been a good chunk of my diet oh my God
anyway the the
I don't accept any liability for what
I'm about to say I think that's fake
news
um yeah I I don't know that I believe
that uh I've I've never gotten poison
from it anyway uh but so okay wanted to
get back to Noodles higher total protein
content gives me more flexibility I
found that um
oh God it just left me what are the
little noodles that basically look like
rice
oh I mean I have no idea uh I'm I'm
gonna get it orzo yeah yeah so uh I
found for whatever reason that like long
noodles that get overly mushy not good
um like macaroni style noodles also not
good uh but like orzo I find that if
it's in the fridge in some sort of like
uh broader meal prep and it gets soggy
like I just don't mind it's fine
um
and so I've I've gone back to that and
I've been I've been getting into the
realm of of cheese sauces for things uh
because also like low moisture part skin
like mozzarella also has like pretty
decent macros
um and so my
previous meal prep was absolutely
incredible so it was three pounds of
orzo about six pounds of chicken thighs
uh 24 ounces of
um tomato paste an enormous amount of
onions an enormous amount of garlic and
uh so like I started the chicken in a
pan
uh like I ground it started it in a pan
let some of the fat render out put in
like six pounds of onions let them sweat
all the way down through some garlic in
then hit it with uh the the tomato paste
a lot of salt a lot of MSG like let that
cook until the tomato paste started
caramelizing picking up a little bit of
color uh kind of the the raw taste uh or
like raw smell getting away from it and
then uh just adding water until it was a
little bit thinner than I wanted and
then I had two pounds of low moisture
part skin mozzarella that I shredded and
then once that whole mixture came up to
a simmer uh just you know turn turn off
the heat so that the cheese doesn't like
overcook and start separating out put
all of the cheese in there mix it until
it's fully combined and at that point
you basically just have like a very
protein rich like cheese sauce which is
[ __ ] incredible and then I boiled the
orzo uh started in and I gotta say it
was
not not just like adequate meal prep for
the macros I'm aiming for but it was
like legitimately [ __ ] good like it
was
um
it wasn't like sort of like the best
vodka sauce that one could get from an
Italian restaurant but it was like if
you just got noodles and like
store-bought vodka sauce and chicken it
was it was like that that level of like
hedonically pleasing uh it was really
great but anyway
um little tip uh orzo for meal prep it's
nice I'd recommend it it's good
um in terms of the experiment that we're
going for for tomorrow so I'm making
burgers
uh you and I are vegetarian not using
beef and so for y'all's Burgers what I'm
gonna do is I got uh just a slew of
mushrooms so some shiitakes some oyster
mushrooms some maitakis I'm gonna cut
them up pretty small but not really
small uh and and basically just cook
them down uh render most of the water
out let them caramelize a little bit and
then uh so I'm doing that tonight so
they'll have time to cool and then for
the burgers themselves I'm gonna toss in
uh some some Dashi a little bit of soy
sauce some liquid smoke maybe
um and an egg and then just like however
much either flour or bread crumbs I'm
not totally sure yet which way I want to
go but just enough to to hold it
together
also plenty of salt in MSG so it's like
very very Savory
um and just add as much flour as is
needed to like make it adhere to to be
like a loose Patty without being like
super super dry
um
and then yeah just just sear it up good
um
and I gotta say I've I mean I've eaten
far too many burgers in my life uh the
the beef burgers I'm gonna make are
gonna be incredible but also not
exciting to me just because I've I'm
very good at burgers and I've had so
many of them but I'm like straight up
very excited for the mushroom burgers
I'm gonna make yeah um
I I think that I will actually prefer
them to the beef ones wow but they're
they're they're they're going to be
something are you grinding up the meat
for the beef burgers yourself yeah yeah
because back in the day you would do all
sorts of elaborate blends of meats and
stuff like that yeah yeah I'm just going
uh because you remember when you first
got the the meat grinder you had Burgers
every meal for like three weeks
it was like eight months
uh but yeah yeah so I'm just I'm just
going short rib
cool but yeah should be nice well I'm
excited man I appreciate all the the
thought and effort going into the
vegetarian accommodation there no
problem and I'm very excited to to taste
that it sounds like it's going to be
awesome sweet
all right uh wrap this up yeah let's do
it
um so once again uh everyone thank you
so much for joining us live on a Friday
night starting your weekend uh you know
joining us for this one year anniversary
celebration of macro Factor uh and
thanks to everyone for your support over
the last year as Greg and I have said
multiple times year one of this big
experiment with macro Factor has totally
exceeded our expectations the uh the
support from all of you has been
absolutely phenomenal we couldn't
possibly be more grateful or
appreciative for that support so thank
you so much for that over the last year
thanks for joining us tonight and
hopefully we'll see you in in exactly
one year for the second anniversary also
before we wrap up I just want to make
sure that everyone behind the scenes
also gets the credit they deserve Eric
and I are the people in front of the
camera uh but
I mean we absolutely couldn't have done
this without the developers Corey and
Rebecca it it cannot be overstated how
[ __ ] good they are and how hard
they've been working this entire year
um like the just straight up without
them the app doesn't exist
um also not trying to score brownie
points but I also couldn't have done
this without Lindsay my wife she is the
silent fifth member of the team who uh
actually just created a Reddit account
today to uh to post the annual report in
the subreddit
um but yeah she's she's not uh around
publicly in the groups but she does a
tremendous amount behind this scenes as
far as design goes marketing managing
the email list making sure that when
Eric and I write articles that are
entirely too long that they are
appropriately edited and the images look
good and yeah I mean she she rocks also
like none of this would be happening
without her and finally last but
absolutely not least Adam Fisher who
handles the vast vast majority of the
support for macro Factor so if you've
ever
um if you've ever like submitted a
support ticket and someone got back with
you there's like a 99.8 chance that was
Adam uh he is incredible and also the
app would not be in the stated as today
without him if he wasn't doing that then
the support burden would mostly then
fall on Corey and Rebecca which would
mean they would have less time to
actually work on the app and create
features so once again his uh his
contribution to macro Factor has been
enormous and and can't be overstated so
um and of course uh like you said all of
the users
um you know just purely in terms of this
being a business we wouldn't have a
business that could continue into the
future without people using the app and
then also just in terms of how good the
app is and the state it's in today
without all of the feedback and feature
requests voting on our public roadmap
all of that that you guys have done uh
the app wouldn't be as good as it is and
in the state it's in today so uh deep
deep appreciation for for all of you
absolutely once again thanks so much for
joining us tonight have a great morning
or afternoon or evening wherever you
happen to be in the world and we will be
back hopefully in one year for the
second anniversary celebration take care